What you will notice is that on Wednesday,
June 26th you have Cory Booker, Elizabeth
Warren, Beto O'rourke, Amy Klobuchar charge
John Delaney Tulsi Gabard who Leanne Castro,
Tim Ryan, Bill de Blasio and Washington governor
Jay Inslee.
Effectively.
What has happened is that the first debate
is basically Elizabeth Warren versus a bunch
of people pulling almost nothing plus Cory
booker and Beto who are pulling a couple of
points but don't seem to have any reasonable
shot in my mind at impressing people so sincerely
and so overwhelmingly that they are going
to be in this thing.
We'll talk in a second whether that would
be good for Elizabeth Warren or not.
And then in the second night of these debates,
you have the heavier hit her front runners.
You've got Bernie Sanders and Camilla Harris
of course, vice president Joe Biden and Pete
booted judge, who are the front runners with
the exception of Elizabeth Warren, who will
be on the first night.
And then joining them.
Michael Bennet, Marianne Williamson, who I
have a hard time believing she even really
has the, the uh, financial support required.
But okay, I don't, I'm not being conspiratorial,
I'm just shocked that she got 65,000 donations.
Eric Swalwell, Kirsten Gillibrand, Andrew
Yang has made the stage, which will be interesting.
John Hickenlooper as well.
So the second night is every other front runner,
but Elizabeth Warren, meaning Biden, Sanders,
Buddha, judge and Kamala Harris.
Does this help or hurt Elizabeth Warren?
Uh, there's two ways to think about it.
Okay.
One approach is this is bad for Elizabeth
Warren because the second night we'll have
a bigger audience because there are more big
players who want to see their favorite debate
rather than people they aren't supporting.
The second night has more polling support
in the aggregate in total.
And so we'll, Elizabeth Warren just is not
going to get the exposure that some of these
other candidates that are going to get.
There's another view though, which is now
this is good for Elizabeth Warren.
First of all, this is the first debate of
the season.
Meaning it's going to be uh, very well, uh,
viewed.
It's going to have a significant audience
and therefore it's not right to assume that
night too.
We'll have more audience night one is going
to have more audience.
The other argument to be made in favor of
Elizabeth Warren is she is clearly the top
dog on the first night.
Therefore, she's going to do really well against
lesser known, less popular candidates.
The, the sort of wrinkle in that argument
is that although Elizabeth Warren is clearly
the front runner of the first night of candidates,
she's not necessarily the best debater of
that first night because as I've spoken about
before, I Love Elizabeth Warren's policy based
approach.
It's been helping her in the polls.
We'll talk about those polling numbers momentarily,
which continue to improve for Elizabeth Warren.
But in large stage debates, I
don't
actually think she's that great.
So it'll be very interesting to see whether
ultimately this is good or bad for Elizabeth
Warren to be segregated front runner in night
one net net net.
I think it probably hurts her a little bit.
I think it will give her a great opportunity
to pull some support from some of the other
people she's debating against.
But that in the context of against the bigger
front runners like Biden and Sanders, uh,
it's a missed opportunity for her by being
on a different night.
But this is just the debate one a right?
There's going to be a lot of opportunities.
So this is, this is just the beginning.
Um, what I also am really interested in seeing
is the Bernie versus Biden dynamic in night.
Two of the debate, which again, this is next
week, not this week.
We've just learned what the lineups are going
to be.
Bernie, during that Fox News Town Hall said,
Oh, Joe's a friend of mine.
Uh, but we have policy differences or whatever.
However it was that he worded it.
That's going to be very interesting and it's
also going to be interesting to see if any
of what I call the one percenters explode
because there have been, listen, Andrew Yang,
who I like has a following that says, as soon
as Andrew Yang gets on a debate stage with
these other candidates, he is going to explode
in the polling because people are just going
to absolutely love what he has to say.
We'll see if that happens.
I'm excited to see if that happens.
Tulsi has a similar following that says as
soon as Tulsi Gabbard is given the opportunity
to debate these other candidates, she will
come through as the right path forward for
the United States of America.
Well, we're going to see very soon, she's
pulling I think 0.4% right now.
Uh, um, or maybe it's up to like 0.7.
We'll see.
Um, Jay Inslee is a guy who has almost no
support, but his supporters believe that he
is really offering the best package of policies
and that as soon as America is fully introduced
to Jay Inslee, Jay Inslee's polling is going
to take off like a rocket ship or whatever
metaphor you want to use.
We'll see.
And I'm excited to see it and we'll talk more
about the pre debate, um, uh, stuff that's
going on later in the week, but probably more,
uh, early, early next week.